hi yes
so i'm
as mike said i'm luis i just moved here
from uh
i did my phd at penn and i just joined
as a postdoc at the for the
collaboration on the theoretical
foundations of deep learning so my
background is actually in engineering
and signal processing and that's how i
got interested into looking at
requirements or embedding requirements
into learning and essentially today i'd
like to answer just four questions
essentially why when how and what's next
or where do i see this going next
so in terms of why let me start by
motivating this idea of learning on the
requirements with
an example essentially in image
recognition now image recognition is a
test that we became exceedingly good at
solving however the solutions that we
obtain are typically quite brittle very
small perturbations of the input can
lead to drastic changes in the accuracy
of the classifier that we obtain and the
typical way to address this problem is
to use this technique known as
adversarial learning where we will
replace the nominal performance measures
so there are loss on on the data that we
have by a perturbed
performance measure simply that embeds
worst perturbations of the cost and
that's a
technique that is quite effective at
increasing robustness so increasing
adversarial accuracy albeit at the cost
of nominal performance or performance on
the clean data the grades due to that
the typical way to deal with these
trade-offs in optimization and machine
learning is to use these techniques
based on penalties where we combine both
of these losses into a single objective
that we then train our model on
the issue with this technique is
essentially related to this parameter
lambda that we need to choose in order
to you know balance those two costs
because there is no straightforward
relation between the value of lambda and
the value of that loss
uh it turns out that we need to find it
essentially by trial and error and that
means that actually the value of lambda
ends up depending on the data
itself which you know raises some
questions about generalization in
particular we can give guarantees from
classical learning on the aggregated
objective generalization but not
necessarily on each of the parts
separately which is the thing that we're
actually interested in doing
so the way that i propose to overcome
this issue is to use constraint
optimization in order to formulate the
exact problem that i wrote on top of the
of the slide right which is
we want to find classifiers that have
the best possible clean performance
among those classifiers that have good
robustness good robustness properties
and here you can see that the robustness
which is a requirement that we impose
actually appears as a constraint rather
than cost so it's slightly more natural
formulation and also has this advantage
of decoupling our measure of performance
from the requirements that we actually
want to impose
now i just want to point out that there
is this idea sometimes that this
constraint problem is somehow related to
the
um
to this penalty-based problem and in the
case of convex problems that is actually
true in non-convex that is not even
typical so there might not exist a value
of lambda that actually provides us with
a solution that is uh feasible or
optimal for this problem right
because strong duality uh need not hold
in in general case however if we were to
go ahead and solve these problems with
methods that i'll show later we can
actually
obtain essentially the same level of
of robustness that we would obtain using
adversarial learning but with a much
better nominal performance and recently
we actually showed
that using these techniques we can
actually obtain state-of-the-art results
in in benchmarks in adversarial learning
now constraint learning is not used only
for adversarial obviously it's a more
general framework that we're interested
in looking and we have even
some examples for example in fair
classification and also in the
reinforcement learning or of safe
policies
now obviously this effectiveness raises
the question but some theoretical
questions in terms of learning of okay
it works but is it true that
when is it possible to actually for us
to learn on the requirements in other
words when is it that the solution of
that empirical problem actually
generalizes right i mean in practice and
it's a simple exercise in a union bound
to show that you know if you can learn
those uh separate losses i mean those
problems if you can solve those learning
problems separately you can solve them
jointly right so in a certain sense in a
learning theoretic sense constraint
learning is not really that different or
much harder than unconstrained learning
however while that tells us something
about generalization it doesn't really
tell us how we're supposed to solve that
uh constraint the rn problem right in
the
in in the typical setting in machine
learning where we're going to have
non-linear functions which means
non-convex problems in the unconstrained
case maybe we can hope to find a local
minimum that perhaps is even good right
using some sort of local search like
gradient descent but here even finding a
feasible problem a feasible solution
might be quite challenging
right and that brings us to our next
question of you know how how
could we go about trying to learn these
problems and it turns out that the
answer is related to the concept of
duality in in optimization optimization
duality is a property that associates to
each constrained problem an
unconstrained problem right which is a
lower bound on the original problem in
certain cases like convex optimization
like i mentioned before it turns out
that these problems can be shown to be
equivalent in in many senses in general
that is not true that doesn't hold so
for the convex problems that we are
looking at here that actually not is is
not a property
so to overcome this this issue what uh
what i use is a technical discovery
essentially that shows that even though
non-convex finite dimensional
optimization problems are typically not
strongly dual it turns out that their
infinite dimensional counterparts
manifest very similar duality properties
as convex optimization problems
essentially
and to give you a concrete handle on
this idea it's essentially means that
you know while sparse logistic
regression is an interactable problem it
turns out that the continuous version of
the problem is actually tractable we can
give an actual algorithm to solve this
problem and uh so you know the barrier
of complexity here of tractability let's
say is no no longer between convex and
non-convex but between discrete and
continuous
essentially now that has a lot of
applications in obviously in functional
sparsity that we have explored but what
matters to us here is the fact that even
though we cannot relate the solution of
the dual to the solution of the primal
problem of the constrained drm problem
we can actually directly show that the
solutions of this empirical do
generalize to the whole population which
is what we actually cared about
i'm not going to go into a lot of
details about this about this type of
results but essentially in practice what
this means is that if we can find if we
are able to solve unconstrained learning
problems approximately then we are able
to solve constrained learning problems
as well
right
using techniques such as dual ascent
in terms of what's next there are a lot
of challenges still in in this problem
there are three things that i would like
to i'd be interested in looking into the
first one is with respect to
applications obviously especially
non-conventional ones like stability
semi-supervised learning also
semi-infinite learning programs which we
have been using for that adversarial
problem and also to learn functions with
smoothness that has a very interesting
connections with sampling as well uh
also i'm interested in algorithmic uh
challenges right i mean those gradient
decent ascent dynamics in non-convex
settings the behavior of these things
are not as well as understood as
gradient descent dynamics and non-convex
settings and also the issue of primal
recovery which is a big problem in
duality
and i'm also interested in looking at
statistical properties especially of
these
dysfunctional sparse problems right
which which have a lot of application
especially and they're used in you know
in order to train and perhaps analyze
infinitely wide neural networks so
uh you can find more information about
this on my website and if there's
anything that you saw here that picked
your interest please feel free to reach
out to me or talk to me during this
next year or so
thank you
[Applause]
release
perfect
[Music]